we're back we're back we're back to
being live we're back to being live
John's gone
no one's here yet let them come that
then come let them partay into here
hello Paul
kotero how's it going buddy gonna wait
till some eyes in here Pablo then I'm
gonna reveal number two Amy O'Neill Amy
up jpq Stevens it's going on Ethan
Abraham how's it going hey bassist glad
to give you some nipple chills buddy I'm
so glad that that's the one thing for
sure I can say I've coined what's up
Andrew Thompson Gregory it's always good
to have another Gregory Amy saying hi
John I she clearly doesn't see me here
hello there Nathaniel Tyrone not the
Magnus Jenna Randolph what's up my dear
Emily Fletcher hello New Japan
highlights yo guys alright once we just
get a few more eyes in here dope trope
number two will be unveiled he's got to
know what dope trope is dope trope is
something I came up with it's probably
it's tropes and movies I'm sick of
seeing and I reveal what number two is
at the end of the last livestream but
that was after like an hour of being
here so I know that most people don't
stick around that long hello wrote it's
really trying to get a a naming
knowledge man in here what's up Rohit
Zack wounds Erik horsemen my dude one
day we'll fly to Atlanta and see you
classy c88 how you doing Julian I've
noticed you done this whole live stream
just gonna be me on noticing people's
names hey Daniel peachy how's it going
so much okay so dope trope number two
here's what it is it's basically the
thing I get sick of in Thank You fidella
for looking out for this I want this to
be a thing that people look forward to
hearing about I mentioned it sitting in
the last livestream it's in action
movies where the character is falling
from let's say a building or a plane
like a usually a female character is
falling and then hero
side of the plane puts their arms like
this and then it causes them to defy
gravity and fall even faster to catch
said here to catch set victim who was
falling from the sky
that's not how gravity works that's not
how physics works John wants to defend
this for some reason there's nothing to
be knows yourself you know laying like a
fish has no facts to go off of here
you're ignoring it's not the way it
works Joe yeah not the same way it's not
the way it works would affect your
trajectory by changing your putting your
arm like that would not make you faster
no wide will maybe not slower you would
have me it would not make you go that
much if someone saw someone it's
followed from a plane if some guy jumps
out like 20 10 to 20 seconds later
there's no way they can get just my
divers can have at least some level of
control over where they're going that's
why there are professional sky you're
talking about a difference in like 1 to
2 seconds of a difference I'm talking
about someone's way the crab let me down
no way I've got a couple of people agree
with me here ok one you got one
agreeance with you here I'm just saying
it's based on a constant okay you have
to fall like right after in order to
catch that person at maximum to catch
them minimum I mean at minimum you catch
them anyway guys help us catch up on
some movie news suggest some topics for
us to talk about and we'll we'll go into
there
come on let's let's hear it let's hear
it or chime in about the dope trip and
who you agree with here let's go with
that we let you guys control the
narrative here thanks michael Roybal
that means a lot that you'd super chat
us right now but I would prefer a
question to go along with that super
chat they fought the same speeds yeah
yeah go to the the example if you drop a
watermelon and an egg they're not
sentient they won't move on I cried gave
you that it would it would they would
you there's ways to make you go faster
or slow
but not in the way how it works what are
your thoughts on a Ryan Gosling at Thor
for Ryan Gosling or for that effect that
thought of your ass making us excitable
really they're talking about Ryan
Gosling and work I would love John look
that up right now I would love that
Ryan Gosling's my homeboy look at my
shirt I'm wearing Gosling on my tea
right now I would absolutely love for
Ryan Gosling being there he is under
rated in the comedy department Lars and
ax and the real girl
the nice guys that if you just watch
them two interviews he is impeccable
comedic timing man he's crazy stupid
love there you go thank you Humphrey and
he was spotted with Taika Waititi which
has got people which means he's
definitely gonna be in it thanks Jimmy
freckles appreciate that buddy I like I
mean I liked super-sweet who doesn't
love a good super chat hey garbage it's
the same side put a question in the
super chat helps guide the narrative of
this live stream a little bit question
that one done
John pick a topic for us well Jimmy
freckles did ask afterwards what our
thoughts are on once upon time in
Hollywood now that we've had a couple
weeks to stew upon it funny enough we
did a Q&A at our patreon page talking
about the ending of one stupid time in
Hollywood and the Bruce Lee controversy
I am I think I'm gonna put that one up
on YouTube though because we want to
take one of our Q&A is from patreon once
a month and put it up there on this
channel and you know I I think it's a
brilliant film I think the best way to
view Once Upon a Time in Hollywood is
not like Tarantino likes to make movies
where you know when you're watching it
he likes the audience to be aware
they're watching a movie at the same
time I think with that film you want to
be aware you're watching a movie you
want to be aware of the reality of what
really happened in that and in the real
story but also you want to be aware
you're watching a Quentin Tarantino
movie when you have all three to those
things at the forefront of your mind
we're just in the back of your mind it
makes for the ultimate viewing
experience and honestly the more I think
about it the more I love
faul my I can't wait to buy the blu-ray
edition check out whatever deleted
scenes Tarantino has to offer us for
that time I want to try and see it at
the new buff before they're done doing
that they keep selling out shows so I
imagine we'll be there for a little
while yeah della elaborate a little bit
more on the move along controversy I
only heard tidbits about it oh yes you
know well I just googled this apparently
Hong Kong protesters are basically
urging a boycott because the star of the
movie said I don't know exactly what the
statement was maybe you guys can
enlighten this but something pro-police
yeah I don't know much about Hong Kong
politics I barely know anything about
our American politics but boy do I have
strong opinions about American politics
even though I don't know half as much as
I should so don't feel entirely
comfortable I'm still gonna watch the
movie if anything this just gains more
attention Oh Daniel Travis okay let's
keep in mind that John wick one on the
birds of prey uh uh chats the hell ski
what is your favorite TV show right now
Daniel Travis wants to know Daniels
Travis this is an easy answer for me
John you want to go first as mine's
pretty easy easy
my no mine right away my favorite TV
show I've seen recently is Russian doll
Russian doll nice good terrific show
yeah really straight to the point there
mine is the boys I have seen all of the
boys I really want this guy to watch it
see one season two comes out I think
we're gonna it's it's tough to work
around with the amount of subject matter
and gore that and sexuality that's in
that in that series but I'll try to do
for like YouTube reaction highlights for
season two because I adored that show of
my girlfriend living at work we were
addicted to it man that is just from
beginning to end into its final moments
of that season hopefully no one ruins it
for you it was nuts man
and yeah I just finished Cobra Kai
season two about a week and a half ago a
lot more serious than season one a lot
darker Miguel's a dick there's a lot
tortured it's at Hawk is like a totally
messed up guy that Crees
it's it's it's also funny because
descents of reality for street fights is
just crazy I can like I learned some
like crazy weird action like kicking
each other in the face
so okay wait Michael Roy ball to
acknowledge thank you for that dollar
super chat much loving some ego and we
have julian garcia wanted to know or are
brought up the news John wick director
chads2 house keys handling reshoots for
birds of prey oh yes okay uh well I
don't know why everyone's flipping out
about it as if it's like a negative
thing people are kind of responding as
if they're the movies in a state of
crisis or something I'm like guys when
you hear that news doesn't does that
make you more excited for what the film
has to offer at that point wouldn't if
you're a fan of the action that's into
his channel in the John wick trilogy
what did that make you go yeah yes it's
gonna be so cool I don't know not that I
know everything about how these action
scenes work in Hollywood films but a lot
of time you have second unit director
you have other people doing a lot of
what comprises the action so yeah
especially in this context it doesn't
really make me worried for the creative
direction of the movie I just now expect
some killer action on top of whatever
cool story they're gonna throw our way
we got a couple of people to Ajaib jpq
stevens have you ever been to Dragon Con
in Atlanta
the boys cast will be there so damn
excited Conan Atlanta never been to
Atlanta but I rub into Atlanta I hear
the gambling department there is a whole
lot of fun
I hear strip clubs they're amazing and
that's the main reason we would go to LA
blow all our money just keep keep super
chatting and we'll just take all that
simulate a low $30 drink it's not it's
not a live stream if Carter Lovejoy is
in here you're our biggest lives
what's this question John Carter Lovejoy
wants to know what do you think it will
take to convince
Bob Iger and Disney to make r-rated
Mickey Mouse raunchy comedy that's easy
a lot of money money just give them
money not the most marketable idea and
the safest idea all this all this [ __ ]
of that people talk about with like
Disney brand and everything that will
all go out the window once they're like
oh wait we can make a lot of money okay
sure let's do it then why the [ __ ] not
if they can appeal as widely as possible
I mean you know it's nice that Disney
does all these loke things but you have
to imagine that they're partially doing
that to get more people to come see
their movies make it just make a
guarantee no once r-rated becomes
mainstream all the way Mickey Mouse
hochy comedy hey Minnie do you like to
be choked you go online and get that
right now everything is you could just
pay somebody on tumblr to make that
reality I feel like there's like you
know probably Walt Disney pornos out
there now right there's gotta be someone
confirm this I confirm this for us I'm
not entirely sure what this DBZ
live-action controversy is that you guys
were talking about you want to care to
elaborate a little more well circle back
to that it's gonna be great
this is totally pre-recorded for for
those who are asking so who else would
be guy here Jaden Perez did you know
Jackie Chan is rumored to play Sankey
that is the Netflix that is the red box
straight to DVD version exchange did you
know Jackie Chan's number two plays
Shane cheese father I do now I I do now
we're like when you hear about what
shang-chi is in the kind of cast I have
assemble for it trying to Chinese people
you go yeah why is it yeah shelli's and
move one foot Jackie Chan shang-chi make
it happen man get everybody you know
like yeah ventually who disney's got to
have every major Asian actor day out it
okay you got look you got the the the
main Chinese actors I grew up on in
terms of Hong Kong cinema Jackie Chan
gently you and Bo sammo hung and
Shelly oh and there was like Maggie
Cheung and stuff but I was more loyal to
the following of those guys so you got
Jackie Chan if Jackie Chan could be in
change she he got Donnie and but Donnie
Yen nowadays he's in Star Wars rogue one
why does he he get offered his own
spin-off show people who totally watch
that [ __ ] I'm so excited for that one
and then and then Michelle Yeoh she's in
discovery right and and then jellies in
Mulan now we just got to get saml ass
and put Sammo hung and something man you
could be the new Jabba the Hutt
make it happen Jon pull another question
here alright alright this is a random
one do you want to see Josh Brolin in
the new Mortal Kombat as Shao Kahn hey
as generic of a choice as that sounds
that would be pretty awesome
we should just start casting whoa that
would be pretty good Shao Kahn is not
white though right and Lynnae my dear to
junior already at our Jimmy will take
her patreon page My Dear John John's
gonna change change in front of the
camera for that of my wrestling I've
gone shirtless for this channel many
times no no take off the shirt it's your
turn to go you want to really burn oh of
course he hasn't under streaming son of
a [ __ ] he's got her under sure got a
workout more got it got a workout
alright put it on yeah hell yeah yes
just for you a name Lynnae Jones cousin
of Indiana
good night oh that's a crazy video you
requested for us that we put up this
week in the SML other crazy channel man
cheffy oh yes okay guys Cobra Kai see I
thought billboard for this - Cobra Kai
season 1 & 2 are gonna be temporarily
available on YouTube for free and I
heard
season three is going to be available as
well Elizabeth Shue is in the boys did
you lose one of the main characters and
I thought that was you wanted the boy I
kid you not the first four episodes of
watching the boys I thought that was
Chelsea Handler I couldn't have widely
convinced I was watching Chelsea Handler
and then I I was looking up for like one
season three coming out and then I
learned about Elizabeth oh that's
Elizabeth you and the boys those of a
shoe is a girl in Karate Kid so that's
why I'm freaking out about now okay see
you guys in shots out to the real
skeleton all of for confirming that
there is Walt Disney porn and he claims
that we owe him now and now he's left
the live stream to go watch a little
more I agree guys though if you haven't
seen Cobra Kai you need to get all that
even if you're not a huge like fan of
the franchise of The Karate Kid I think
if you just liked the first Karate Kid
and then you want two and three I've
never seen the one with Hilary Swank but
yeah I think if you just watch the first
Karate Kid and you hop on a Cobra Kai
seriously that is that that is one hell
of a show it really is a fantastic show
so Greg yeah now that we've got DC
Universe I've got the DC Universe as DC
Universe are you gonna watch all of the
DC Universe shows are you gonna swamp it
out I'll try to thanks Erik horsemen
buddies kitchen horseman Micha hollowed
you know if you're a patron I feel
enormous guilt already showing your
support
so what's the question I'm sorry oh yeah
I've been using the DC Universe app
primarily to read a little bit more
comics I started reading one of the
birds of praise comic series the front I
think from 2010 or 2011 and then I've
been going through the archives of
Harley Quinn comics like these Lego
sometimes to catch up I'll do like us
what are the essential comic books to
read and so I've been going read just
last night Harley Quinn Mad Love
really adored that I I skipped a Suicide
Squad number seven that was great
that was what really short but great
seriously like the way they organized
the the app for comic books is
incredible
I've yet to watch any of the shows is it
only free comics and I've also I've also
watched the DC animated movie Justice
League the the flash paradox one where
that one's so cool
that's basically flash sheet time
travels he [ __ ] up the timeline and
Bruce Wayne actually died in the alley
his father fools Thomas Thomas Wayne
becomes Batman we use guns and he's
violent an Aquaman and Wonder Woman are
at war with each other it's really dark
but awesome it's so cool if you guys
haven't seen Jeff if you guys haven't
seen that DC animated movie you really
should go check it out but in terms it's
answer your question the show's yeah I
would I would love to start up Titans I
know I know someone who works on Titans
and it's got a pretty important job on
there I don't think you want to say who
is but he really loves like I felt guilt
every time I see him I'm like damn and I
am sorry Titans yet ok Tigers but I
actually really want to see Swamp Thing
personally and over and I mean I keep
hearing great things about Doom Patrol
do patrols the one most gravitates you
so what Erik horsemen have you seen mine
hunter season 2 yes last night
life plus fringe reunion with Cerberus I
never really watched that much fringe I
feel bad now for not knowing your
reference more intimately are you
planning on watching I loved what yeah
yeah I watched season one over your
shoulder yeah and yeah are usually
cooking right yeah yeah cooking over
we're behind you at the other table and
yeah I really like season 1 and you know
I and the amount of time it's taken I'm
like ooh that's the right time for some
more mine hunter it's always the right
time for mine hunter III playing Olivia
and I are planning on watching my hunter
season two their shows
their shows I'll watch for patreon shows
a watch for YouTube then their shows
where I'm like I cannot watch that
without my girlfriend and if I need to
record it like stranger things a game of
Thrones she will be in the video magma a
big everyone satisfied in that
department but yeah mine hundred season
two we're gonna I think we're gonna
start up sometime this week she just
works pretty late and so yeah Tarantino
or Spielberg whatever you know I mean
yeah I would probably go through all I
could go through like all the semantics
all the details technicalities of how
there are entirely different filmmakers
waitin comparing yes at the end of the
day yet Tarantino has probably affected
me the most
yeah and I would probably there's not a
Tarantino movie I wouldn't be happy to
watch whereas I'm sure that across
Spielberg's career there would be
somewhere I rely so someone was asking
about our dream MCU movie we did a one
of the most loose video podcast we've
ever done that was about our Avengers
dream team up movie and I had one that
was all about just the street-level guys
who had the team up like Hawkeye Black
Widow daredevil only one person that
wasn't a super like that was kind of
super sort of struck star-lord but
having to take on Wilson Fisk be my
Punisher in there too yeah but if that
act actually I would like if you guys
watch that podcast that was a really fun
we had a lot of technical issues that we
really kept rolling with a car girl
already Mickey Mouse tough one oh this
is oh he just wants to pay you okay
here's the pitch
John pitch a picture proudly reopened
touchstone to give I Guren company sixty
million dollars to convince them to make
it and three make it 2d animated this is
this is to see you gotta you gotta pitch
this market ibly man I'm thinking this
needs to be 3d animate I would love a 2d
animated but if you're talking what
makes money it's probably gonna have to
be 3d very what yeah we isn't
Toodee more expensive to produce because
you have to draw every moment you have
to draw every frame I don't exactly know
because I know that at least some of
that work gets shipped out overseas and
probably not paid very much for but yeah
I got to imagine that the investment is
pretty substantial yeah it's a lot more
time there's a reason why a lot of
people were let go - it's more than just
the fact that 2d animators weren't
trained in three animation it's just
it's less time it's cheaper that's
different
that's why it was a big deal when Brad
Bird did you know taking your dance I'm
taking your pitch for this already
Mickey Mouse if there's a reason why it
was a big deal that for Brad Bird when
he did Incredibles ratatouille that he
that he had that they hand drew the
whole thing first as if they were doing
2d animation and then they did 3d
animation overlays because that's just
way more time-consuming it's a lot more
labor to do the 2d so in fact I think 3d
you got a better chance of convincing
Baba especially because their own
attempts to revitalize 2d they did not
really hold on to thanks for taking us
some chat space there Jimmy freckles Oh
Jimmy freckles Louie jump wants to know
what's the best Sam Raimi movement
really quick okay we're gonna answer
that but there's a lot of people chiming
in on your on your idea Carter love door
I think you're onto something in the
movement let's get a petition Disney's
horn reading live stream chat is like
brain on major ATT so what was the job
once you go you're a big salmon fan of
ramie movie best Sam Raimi movie ooh
that's actually the best the
pound-for-pound best made Sam Raimi film
was the great in the power cycle through
all the ones I wish were better
now um you go up to drag me to hell I've
heard I've heard people say like drag me
to hell we love you too people say drag
me to hell and a lot of ways is like
well it's it's just a it's a sort of a
refined or different version of what
we've already seen him do with things
like Evil Dead - I would I would argue
against that I think you get a lot of
what you get from Evil Dead - especially
that one in that movie but I feel that
his direction on that film was a lot
more sharp and I think there's an actual
narrative that more people can latch on
to I guess as much of a quarter it is
Evil Dead - his and as monumental and
like horror horror comedy film making
especially that it became and iconic as
it is I would say drag me to hell
definitely has a more fleshed out
character and storyline that I feel is
more attainable for an audience and and
and still manages to weave in all that
crazy bonanza so I purse I personally
feel drag me to hell is as best that but
I know most people probably say go to
Evil Dead and Evil Dead - something like
that most people would say that hence
yes spider-man - yeah so my it's still
my favorite one of the spider-man's
well I I mean I will always have a very
soft spot in my heart for just the first
spider-man because that opened my world
up in a whole other way that was I think
I was the first like real blockbuster
that a super fell in love with and you
know that's true that's true
John pull out something let's see what
someone has to say let's do what wait is
John Bailey here oh what's up ignore him
boys
ignore him ignore him hey I can't stand
that guy
no John Bailey you want to come back on
the channel sometime soon buddy epic
voice guy hanging out with John Bailey
is like hanging and I I imagine it's
kind of like hanging out with the Woody
doll it whatever you tell me pull woody
string he he how he says a different
sentence it's like a different
impression or accent everything like
every new sentence of John Bailey it's a
whole lot of fun you got to keep up with
this razor-sharp improv wits needs your
own action
figure my friend there's a bunch I keep
seeing just just to quell the thirst
what do you think of the prospect of a
Big Trouble in Little China remake
I don't think definitely I don't think
how they should do it no I don't think
you should do it at all it's such a
specific product of its time and it's so
tied to Kurt Russell and James Wong and
like a couple people you know yeah I
don't know why someone would want to
remake that movie and I believe that
someone is the rock not what I think
about Chris Terrio being hired as a
screenwriter for the rise of Skywalker I
have I don't know I mean I Pete a lot of
people look towards like Justice League
and he wrote argue DVS in Justice League
but they forget about other movies that
he wrote that were pretty damn good you
know or go and the thing it's it's kind
of difficult honestly to to look at what
John was stretching all right I'm gonna
stretch right now well the thing with a
lot of these bigger films especially
ones of these of this caliber is a lot
of the time this screenwriter is
whatever he originally conceived has
usually drastically changed that are not
really allowed to talk about it for a
long period of time and they're having
to rewrite things constantly due to the
needs of and it's usually not even them
who's rewriting it there's also it's a
lot of uncredited writers so it's kind
of hard to like weirdly is like my main
passion is actually writing and then
when you look at a lot of these major
studio films it's it's hard to go off of
faith that of how a movies product might
turn out based off of who wrote it
occasionally there's writers like Aaron
Sorkin for the big films the directors
really want him to be hands-on they want
to strictly involve for every step of
this rewrite process until the movie is
done but most of the time writers gotta
like here you go
what that
wasn't what I wrote to you and then it's
up on the screen I think JJ has a lot
more sway over this project than Chris
Terrio yeah you know I think there's a
lot of negativity a lot of shade that's
gonna be going Chris Terios way but
there's a lot of producers there's JJ
Abrams input there's a lot more of that
which are gonna factor in more to the
screenplay than all see what Chris
Terrio is gonna be providing John Bailey
wants to know what did everybody think
of the TJ Miller voice and the
underwater trailer we watched today
that's what because I was that your
voice TJ Miller
that's a John bass I'm Bailey Hopson
here to promote the epic voice guy
channel right away guys it's Ziggler
residuals is that really uh I mean I
wouldn't be surprised John Bailey I've
heard his voice so many times on things
that I'm like oh [ __ ] that's John
Bailey's voice I wouldn't be surprised
but that's cool that was the best part
of the trailer John best part right
there seeing TJ Miller come back for a
random dramatic role all right guys
we're gonna wrap this up in a minute or
two but John grab another grab another
question here let's see do you think
predator and alien will begin
interacting with Marvel now because I
mean Superman fought alien this is the
crossover forget x-men and the Fantastic
Four is looking at one honestly
that have you guys seen that that short
film from forever ago where Batman sunny
now the Joker then the predator shows up
and then the alien shows up and that
right there was such a bomb short film
if anything I'd want to see that one I
forgot what it was called going end game
Batman end game I forgot what that was
called if you guys happen to know you
know say it alright so there are two
questions I found here all right John
are we guys gonna be real directors
after we leave you to know maybe I've
definitely been pursuing a lot more
writing lately
do I can't there are things I can't talk
about publicly apparently getting
stripped off the ground is a lot longer
a process you know that's the thing is
how you don't want to announce something
so early because they're always gonna
ask when's this happening
dead end that's what it's called when's
it's gonna once it's gonna be happening
when's it coming out but a lot of times
with like especially something like what
I have going on right now it's it's a
long process but I'm not directing it
but directors already got a couple of
investors on board once we got
everything going I can make an official
announcement about an actual thing I
wrote and that I wrote it for stereo
partnered up man but we not sure what I
could actually say whatever the hell I
want I just kind of want to keep a
little bit of it secretive yeah you
could brag I wanted to prematurely right
now I wrote it in the last three months
of last year and it's been going through
a lot of there's been some stages of
awesome development that's all I'll say
I'm not gonna be in it it's just
something I scream play I wrote and it's
been it's been good come with the
projects going through stages I'll say
that I'll say that see us directing
Fantastic Four I somebody just asked who
we want us to do
rapper Brad Bird would be perhaps a bit
of her pick maybe a perfect pick right
there he would I would trust Brad Bird
above all else I don't know if I would
be like giddy yes you know like I know
you can do alright John ended on this
wrong note find one more strong one one
more question
one more questions i'ma go I'm gonna do
a
wait for him and then we're gonna depart
the potted [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] cat qex I talked with Roxy Starr
about how Bostonians say [ __ ] kak
sucka do you think the Disney and
long-term is going to ruin cinema and
movie creativity no no I don't I don't
think I don't think so at all I think
there's just it's just one of the stages
in Hollywood right now Hollywood always
goes through like crazy different stages
and do do they currently have the
juggernauts do you currently own the
biggest properties yeah and maybe they
will for for as long as we're alive sure
but no I don't I don't think so there's
like a kajillion movies that are made a
year there's streaming now then there's
like there's so much man
like there's it's just yeah the big eye
the eyes go on the big juggernaut hits
all the time but within every weekend
when there's a juggernaut released
there's also like five other movies that
came out yeah and you have your Disney's
but you also have your a twenty fours
and your people who are on the other
side who did you are here for the
mission of like let's advance cinema
let's give platforms to interesting
voices and whatnot and there's no
shortage of the indie side I think the
main question truly is just where will
we see the creativity land because you
know III would be astonished if creative
original films just vanished because
Disney but you know things yeah things
will change but that'll never go away
because you know that's why people get
into movies it's like doesn't even admit
that no they didn't and they did not
have any violence I want everyone to
know that no he did he did in 1994 1994
we're like what is this alright guys
thank you so much for being here any
questions we did not get around to
apologize subscribe to the epic voice
guy YouTube channel that's the first
thing you should do follow him on
Stardust thank you for being here
tune in for the next live stream we
might do a top five you might just talk
movie news but for sure what is
guaranteed don't row number
three take care people you've been great
1 million subscribers what